We're back in LA for the next two weeks
after having lived here for three years,
and in a way, everything feels so nostalgic to me.
I tried to wake up before my older kids do,
which doesn't always work,
but today it did.
So I got my skincare routine in and ran lucky shower for him,
trying to get him to use sunscreen,
so I apply it for him every morning,
and this one has been my favorite one.
You guys know I need my hot cup of tea,
so I did that next.
Lately, it's been peppermint tea with some lemon and honey.
After that, I hopped on a quick meeting before getting my kids dressed.
My parents already fed them some breakfast,
so this is their second breakfast,
but they wanted some banana bread,
so I got started on making that by mashing up some bananas,
adding all of my wet ingredients before adding my dry ingredients.
And some chocolate I chopped up,
gave that good mix,
popped that in the oven
before setting the kids up with some coloring stuff
so lucky and I could unpack our bags and get our closet organized.
Usually leave everything in suitcases,
but since we're gonna be here for a second,
I decided to just unpack it all.
After we unpacked everything,
I got started on doing my makeup.
I need to do my makeup in order to feel productive.
I don't know what it is,
but I mastered my Makeup routine to where
only takes me 15 minutes every morning.
Also, my lip combo is the Cork lip liner from Mac,
a beniflora from benefit,
and then whatever lip gloss I can find.
Know what to wear this morning?
But I decided on this little romper situation at this point.
The kids wanted to swim in the pool,
so that's what they did
while I went back inside and pulled out my banana bread.
I sliced them up a couple slices
and also made them a little fruit plate I ended up eating.
I'm trying my hardest to stay hydrated,
so I always take my liquid IV wherever I go.
They've come out with so many new flavors since I started using them,
and I love having them on hand.